name a more iconic duo than eSports and
cringe in fact just recently the
internet collectively cringed over the
embarrassing Philadelphia fusion
overwatch roster announcement video is
it birthday by the dancing stop no I'm
sad this keyboard must be broken or
something
somebody's got to be cheating the game
who is this carpet guy that's how we do
in infinity it was actually so bad but
not only did the team take down the
video it also inspired us to put
together this list off the top 10 most
cringe moments in eSports
you won't believe your eyes in our pick
for number ten the amazingly awkward
team introductions from the han tour
2013 finals that is if you have your
night vision goggles handy lions eSports
Club starting off with the team they're
led by their captain and jungle player
hand skin there we go there we go all
right that'll round it out for your
lions eSports Club good luck guys we
were taking number nine is Team Liquid
intro from 2013's g1 Champions League
season 5 which combines deadpan delivery
with the production value of a high
school AV Club kind of Tolerance called
for cystic the kind of dormancy called
onions victory will never come to mus
alone to be victorious
be prepared meet you on the battlefield
some of the best cringe moments come
from when someone is trying just a
little too hard to be funny an ad for
the IGN Pro League was exactly that and
earns itself number 8 on our list
[Music]
eSports personalities hearthstone and
blind dates what could possibly go wrong
yes our pick for number 7 is the
infamous twitch show which featured
eSports personalities playing a digital
card game while attempting small talk
it's ten glorious episodes of pure
cringe greetings travelers and welcome
to the hottest dating scene sweeping the
nation fireside and show pad the sky my
love life as a carson card tough one I I
guess something like a Regnerus I could
hit me as well where sometimes going
great sometimes
and either way I'm putting it all in and
hopefully I don't kill myself I went on
a date with the guy who did the Naruto
run everywhere he and even when I wasn't
paying attention to him he would do it
very slowly next to me so I couldn't
even pretend I didn't know him and then
he threw away trash and did like an
anime pose it was like this I was like
I'm your sim PI I was like all right
this is I'm gonna call me over this is
that when it comes to interviews some
eSports athletes can be a touch awkward
however in our pick for number six I boy
at world's 2017 set a new bar with one
of the most cringe leadplayer interviews
of all time he should say no go too much
Indian college Amelia hello
[Applause]
game of the day versus SKT it is so
important I bought I bought outside of
not picking Lucian how are you guys
gonna beat SKT
thank you very much I boy fantastic
performance and lovely interview coming
in at number five is the shudder
inducing cosplay contest at Gamescom
2012 it is particularly memorable thanks
to the failure to ask the winner if they
needed a translator before putting him
on stage what went into making this
costume how long did it take I'm French
French I'm French he's French well we'll
just admire then Haeju might have won
the Dreamhack winter 2013 Starcraft 2
tournament but in our pick for number
four we're all losers as we watched him
and Dreamhack CEO struggling to open a
giant champagne bottle alright it's
gonna remove the top hit at any second
now the cork is broken and a half do
okay we need a bottle opener if anyone
has a fork okay okay Robert oh and the
CEO Dreamhack is gonna put his pink okay
this is a bottle of liquid are you ready
for number three that's right it's the
counter Pitt hype guy who needs no
further introduction you put your hands
in the air
for eSports and awkward handshakes can't
seem to stay away from each other so
coming in at number two is one of the
worst that's right now
[Music]
and taking the top spot on the list is
the infamous we are fnatic video
featuring the Swedish major winning csgo
team you know a video is epic in its
cringe factor when the team itself
deletes it from their channel and to
this day
nothing has topped it's pure awkwardness
when they go
[Music]
that's how it's been since powers in
this minivan Pompeii and the council Jim
Anderson I was
and those were our picks for the top 10
most cringe moments in eSports and while
we've had our cakes poking fun at the
cringe of others we can't say we've been
a mean to it ourselves so here are some
of the most cringe videos the score
eSports has produced enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
League of Legends
[Music]
what's your name
oh you're interviewing me what are you
doing on this car getting interrogated
not a bad thing though so far not so
good okay so what are you doing tonight
like are you whining this car with a sec
where you going I'm gonna keep down my
cloud nine man is white alright thank
you so much for the interview good luck
tomorrow and thank you guys thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button